- I'm truly delighted
today to host Lan Duong
who is a pathbreaking scholar
working at the intersections
of cinema studies,
Asian American studies,
Vietnamese studies, Asian studies,
and critical diaspora studies,
critical refugee studies,
and truly is one of the
most important voices
at the intersections of all these fields.
Dr. Duong is an Associate Professor
in Cinema and Media Studies
at the University of Southern California
and the author of "Treacherous Subjects:
Gender, Culture, and
Trans-Vietnamese Feminism,"
and a wide range of
important journal articles
and book chapters.
I just wanna say a word about her book.
It's truly pathbreaking.
It introduces new ways of
intersectional analysis
that break down all sorts
of disciplinary boundaries.
It not only critiques the legacies
of colonialism and imperialism,
but takes on the fraught
challenge of engaging
with ideologies of traditionalism,
gender hierarchies, nationalism,
and does this all through
the provocative concept
of treachery as expressed
in both Vietnamese
and diasporic representational practices
and lived experience.
For the sake of this gathering today
in the context of a council
on Southeast Asian studies,
I wanna signal how important the book is,
not only as a work of cinema studies,
but for Lan's a complete scholarly project
being especially important
for the way in which it transcends
a deeply problematic fictional divide,
that for so long has separated scholars
working in Asian studies
from those working in
Asian American studies.
For concept of trans-Vietnamese feminism
and her method of studying both Vietnam
and the Vietnamese diaspora
within what she calls the
same coordinates of time
and space, for example,
is truly a clarion call for more work
that pushes beyond the
methodological nationalism
of area studies and also the US centrism
of so many other fields.
I suspect that the title of today's talk,
On Water is part of this way of thinking,
thinking outside the little
buckets of scholarship
we tend to think with.
I like to think of water as something
that we pour into buckets,
and it sometimes takes the
shape of those buckets.
But if we jostle the buckets,
the water can leap out beyond
the bounds of those buckets
and mingle with the
waters of other buckets
and take on new shapes.
So I'm excited to see what happens today
when Professor Duong shakes things up
and gives us new ways of looking
at trans-Vietnamese cinema,
social life, politics, and history.
So please join me in
welcoming professor Lan Duong.
(Erik claps)
- Thank you.
Thank you, Erik for that
wonderful introduction.
It sounds like both you
and my mom read the book,
so that's very nice. (chuckles)
Kidding.
But I wanted to say thank
you to Erik as well.
And Quan Tran for inviting me
and being a part of this space.
It's really an honor,
and a pleasure to talk to you
today about my talk On Water
and refugee memories in
Vietnamese diasporic films.
So I'm gonna share screen now.
And I begin with Lin and
Lam's very beautiful image
called Tomorrow I Leave.
And as you can see, there is
from what I'm sketching out,
a predominance or
preoccupation with water,
both in art and films of the Vietnamese
and Vietnamese diaspora.
And so today in terms
of films, especially,
I'm gonna be talking about Tran Anh Hung's
La Pierre de l'Attente,
Khoa Do's Mother Fish,
Trinh T. Minh-ha's Forgetting Vietnam
and Quyen Nguyen-Le's Nuoc.
So in terms of looking at these films,
I'm looking at them through the lens
of trans-Vietnamese feminism
and critical refugee studies
to argue that water
resonates in these films
as both a membrane, as a container,
as a bucket to use Erik's
term and as memory.
And I argue that it's a conduit
for the transfer of knowledge
and the ocean itself becomes an archive
for dead refugee bodies, but
also of stories and secrets.
And the films relay this
tension and poignancy,
both sonically and visually.
Such works convey waters
rehabilitative mode
of tending and containing refugee grief
and diasporic memory.
So I'm gonna introduce
three modes of looking
that I use in order to
look at these works.
One of them is trans-Vietnamese feminism
based on the book Treacherous Subjects
that I'd written so long ago,
but it's still relevant to me in terms
of looking at the
geopolitical arrangements
of power in Vietnamese culture,
in terms of, and I'm returning
to Erik's terms here.
In terms of seeing both Vietnam
and the diaspora in the same
coordinates of time and space.
Ultimately, it's a method of analysis
that looks at these at Vietnam
and the vexed relations
the country shares with
its foreign others,
which include Western countries
like the US and France,
as well as the diaspora and
its outer lying neighbors.
I focus on those who
have been marginalized
by such politics, hence the
name treacherous subjects,
because these treacherous
subjects tend to be women,
ethnic minorities and sexual minorities
or gender non-binary subjects.
In terms of critical refugee studies,
Yen Le Espiritu and I wrote an essay
on Syrian Vietnamese women artists.
And in this essay we talked
about feminist refugee
epistemology or FRE.
And this was an important
concept for us to push forward.
And it is a way to turn away
from the spectacularization
of refugee suffering that
often headlines global corporate media
to dislocate the masculinist
and nationalistic forms
of refugee memory that are made public
in local and global spaces.
And so as you see on the screen here,
we looked at Syrian borne
artist Nisrine Boukhari
in a work installation
called Unreceived Letters.
Can you hold on for a bit,
I should close my window.
Can you hear the motor, lawnmower?
Can anyone hear the lawnmower?
- [Quan] I cannot hear it, no.
- [Erik] I can't hear it. It's fine.
- Okay, that's great.
And so this is a very quiet installation
where Boukhari wrote letters
to her family back in Syria,
she's in the Netherlands right now,
exiled from her own country and
she invites the participants
to rifle through the letters, you know,
making their marks with their fingers
on these pieces of paper
and read through them
within a very private gendered space,
as you can tell with the little doilies.
And it's that intimate space
of interiority that Espiritu
and I wanted to emphasize.
On the right, you'll see
that kind of interiority
in gen... My cats, quiet!
And it's really a mode of
retyping, retranslating
some of the letters
that were sent to those
who perished in the seas
during their boat passages.
And so the white panels
hang from the ceiling,
as you can see, the white
panels being symbols of mourning
for those who, for those who died.
And so FRE probes the
spaces of interiority
and the modes of silence
that in hearing them.
And in terms of those modes of silence,
it's important for us to think about
what these silences
say and what they mean.
How can we look at these spaces
and understand the silences as well
as the ways that as Qatari,
another critical refugee
study scholar has said,
"How do we understand these spaces
and these narratives as ways
to restory displacement."
And she takes the concept of
restory-ing from Chinua Achebe
and so a C or S methodology in short
magnifies the political forces
that underlie these intimate sites
and quite often the domestic space.
And I'll be using that
these kinds of lenses
to read the films as you'll see.
Another term that I like to introduce here
is the idea of Refugee Cinema
and what Kaur and Grassilli argue
is the open poethics of Fifth Cinema
and refugee cinema is an emergent subfield
within film studies.
And these authors argue
that refugee cinema
is more distinctly,
a Fifth Cinema, first cinema
being what Hollywood produces.
Second cinema being the more
European art house films.
Third are the kinds of films
that came out in the 1960s and seventies
from Africa, Latin America, and Asia
in a more mode of decolonization.
So Fifth Cinema is one in
which these authors argues
embodies a multifaceted spectrum of films
made by or with the active
participation of refugees.
And quote, "its aim is
to elicit social action,"
and they call for a political resonant
and resistant Fifth Cinema
that outline the innovative often digitize
and dangerous means that
refugees produce their work
and often collaborate
with others in this mode
of media making.
So I understand the open
poethics of Fifth Cinema,
and I examine these films to underscore
the kind of ethical,
political and poetic...
The ethics, poethics and politics
that underlie them as they relate
to refugee memories and post memories.
And today I'll begin with the works
of Vietnamese diaspora
filmmakers chronologically.
And the first one that I'd like to talk
about is Tran Anh Hung's
La Pierre de l'Attente
which was done in 1991, or
it's called the Waiting Stone.
And I bring this movie with
Vietnamese, Australian director,
Khoa Do's Mother Fish
that was made in 2009
because both of these films are used
a certain studio setting to talk
about refugee loss and grief.
And then in the second
part of my presentation,
I'm going to turn to the more recent films
by Trinh T. Minh-ha, Forgetting Vietnam
and Quyen Nguyen-Le's Nuoc.
Both of which were made in 2016
to bring all of my
methodological strands together.
And so to place them within
a framework of cinemas
that are worth not only
looking at, but listening to.
So to begin Tran Anh Hung
as many of you probably know
is a very famous Vietnamese,
French director of films
like Scent of Green Papaya, Cyclo
and Vertical Ray of the Sun.
And this film is actually a student film,
which he made when he was a student
in film school in Paris.
And I am attracted or drawn to this film
because of the ways in which
it really sets a precedent
in my imagination of the kinds
of critical preoccupations
about women's conditions,
about their everyday lives,
the quotidian and the ways
in which aesthetically
Tran Anh Hung likes to very much focus
on women's faces and gestures.
So these two films that I'll
be talking about back to back
are held together by the
slender aesthetic thread
that pulls them together
in my critical imagination.
And that is the unspectacular
ways that refugee memories
are housed in the most
minimalist of spaces.
The settings for each,
a bleak Parisian
apartment and a sweat shop
that serves as a vessel for the boat,
relay how refugee memories root themselves
in gendered spaces of
interiority and of the cycle.
And the reason why I place them
under the ethics of refugee media making
is because they are refugee
themselves, Tran Anh Hung is
and Khoa Do is the second generation
of refugee of...
He's the child of refugee
clearance in Australia,
but they tried to be as
refugee-centric as possible.
They wrote their own scripts
and they worked collaboratively
with refugees or the children of refugees
in the making of their films.
So here I emphasize the cinematic reframe
within both of the films and
that is the absence of boats.
In lacking the visualization
of boats on screen,
the two directors underscore more so
the oral aspects of refugee trauma.
And so that in so doing,
they draw meaningfully on
the connotations of water
or Nuoc in Vietnamese.
Nuoc as others have explored
means both water and country.
But being adrift in water is a condition
domain to the boat people experience
in which refugees fleeing Vietnam
after the Vietnam war ended in 1975,
onto rickety boats, waiting for rescue
is a pragmatic experience for boat people.
In her evocative essay, Salt/Water,
Patricia Nguyen turns to performance
and her family's oral histories
to theorize how water invokes freedom,
"Freedom but also death,
and is the site and
material for disrupting
land-based logics of Vietnamese subject
formation epistemologies."
So like Nguyen I call attention
to the ocean's harboring
of refugee subjectivities
and their epistemologies.
So in terms of Tran Anh Hung student film,
La Pierre de l'Attente,
it's based on a Vietnamese folk tale
called the Waiting Stone or Home Wang Fu.
And it tells the story of
patriarchy's misrecognition
of the incestuous other,
which is the sister and the construction
of The Waiting Woman,
who's reproduced or
produced and reproduced here
as a result of her loyalty to her husband
after she, after they find
out or the brother finds out
that they are in fact, both
married and brother and sister,
he flees and she return,
or she stays in her home,
but becomes The Waiting Woman.
And there's actually a rock
sculpture in Northern Vietnam of
The Waiting Woman where she
is petrified into stone,
the figure is, while
she's holding her son.
So this folk tale in the filming version
is reused interestingly,
in ways that reflect on the
Vietnamese refugee experience.
And it updates the legend to
a more contemporary setting
where the characters arrive
at a refugee camp in Indonesia
and are then relocated to France.
And in my mind,
the move just speaks an innovative
and creative use of a studio setting
where the refugee camp
set and the drab interiors
of an apartment in Paris.
So we shift from the camp's
barracks to the blocking lines
of a gray building.
And the two set pieces
are highly suggestive
of the ways that refugee lives appear
to involve endless forms of waiting,
as they're processed, as
refugees at the camps,
and then become immigrants
in their new environments.
Waiting as it were to begin again.
So I wanted to begin
here with a short clip
of this moment where we're in the camps
and we have Tran Nu Yen Khe
who is Tran Anh Hung's partner and wife
in an earlier film of his who
plays the main protagonist.
And then we also have
LumLe who is a director,
a Vietnamese, French director
himself who plays the brother.
And in this introduction,
I wanted to have you
think about the ways that,
again, we're in, we're
set in a studio setting,
which has been redone
as the camps barracks.
(people chattering)
(baby crying)
(women laughing)
(foghorn blaring)
(people chattering)
- (speaking in foreign language)
Okay.
The only clip that I could
get was actually on YouTube
and with Spanish subtitles.
Otherwise the film is only
available from what I can tell
in a space called Cinematheque in Paris.
And that's how I got access to the film.
But so apologies in
advance for the subtitles,
this introduction though says
a lot through the gestural
and through the use of
light and the sonic tapestry
that I wanted to have you think about.
So this young woman
levers us into the story
when she enters the film frames
and steps into the refugee camp,
generically named as such
in the French subtitles.
Amid children playing and
men and women talking,
the sounds in the camp
signal a hum of activities.
In the background you also
hear ocean waves and foghorns,
and instead of a fishing
village, as you see,
or as you know,
from the Vietnamese legend,
it's what's cited here
is the camp itself where the siblings bond
as a direct result of having
survived the boat passage alone.
During their spare dialogue,
the hues of the sequence
evoke a semblance of warmth,
even as it's set in the
bareness of the barracks.
So I note the sound color
and tone of the scene
because they contrast dramatically
with the following scenes,
where the couple now husband and wife
live in a Parisian apartment complex
that is dreary and devoid of sound.
So with this change of scenery,
we move from the warm sounds
and palette of the ocean
and the camp to a soundless new year
and the muted colors of
their resettlement in France.
So in accommodating the myth to the story
of the Vietnamese displaced,
Jun reimagines of folktale
to tell a bleak story of
loss and wars after life.
And this reframing further locates,
the brother and the husband and the sister
and the wife's estrangement
within the confines of
their new surroundings.
So that while the film
sounds out a confucianus tale
about women's endurance,
the familial story that Jun retells
is lined with refugee desires to leave
and fears in both their
host and home countries.
And the devastation of the
film then is internally tied
to Vietnamese refugees and
their transnational journeys
and the material and existential losses
that they have incurred along the way.
So what I argue is that the
film emphasizes a sense of exile
and grief that are restory'd here in a way
that speaks over the moralistic
and patriarchal overtones of the legend.
And the director adjust us instead
to how refugees endeavor
to not only survive
the oceanic passage,
but also survive the
resettlement experience as well.
I'm gonna move on to mother...
(people chattering)
Mother Fish by
Vietnamese-Australian, Khoa Do.
And so like Tran Anh Hung's La Pierre,
the film begins with a
black screen replaying
in the backdrop voices that are familiar
to an Australian public.
Former Australian prime
minister, Kevin Rudd
discusses the draconian
raft of refugee policies
called the Pacific Solution.
So you hear in the background
while a black screen plays
of a reporter talking or
asking Prime Minister Rudd
on the possibility of
reopening Christmas island
as a site to process asylum planes.
And Rudd vaguely responds,
there's a purpose-built
facility there for that purpose.
So following this empty rhetoric,
that there's a sound
bridge of running water
that leads us into the kitchen
where a Vietnamese woman
soundlessly prepares a meal.
So from here,
we moved to a factory setting
where the refugee passage
is again, reenacted and reimagined.
So I wanted to play a quick clip of that,
of the films beginning.
- [Male Voiceover] Take people
when they're intercepted
in Australian waters,
that's where they go.
Secondly, there's a
purposeful facility there
for that purpose.
And as far as I know,
and no recent advices,
there is still a capacity there.
But as the ministers made
claims for a long, long time.
- [Female Voiceover]
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Male Voiceover] Of course
had additional capacity
of Darwin and other places
should that become necessary.
What we've dealt with in the last-
- [Female Voiceover]
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Male Voiceover] Is the-
- [Female Voiceover]
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Male Voiceover] A
civil war in Sri Lanka-
- [Female Voiceover]
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Male Voiceover] Across the world.
- Okay, so in that quick clip,
you hear Rudd's voice in a,
in a voiceover that is also
intermingled with the sounds of
cooking and it's within
these unspectacular confines,
that the story of Vietnamese
boat people really emerges.
And while she's preparing her food,
the woman hears another
woman's voice as you heard,
which turns out to be
her younger sister Han.
Speaking to her playfully
in an interior monologue
that plays out in the
beginning and end of the film,
but what also begins
and ends with the film,
but what also begins and ends the film
are the sounds of water
and the two sisters reunite in water.
Actually they have submerged in water
and it's a coming together
that we actually see on screen.
But before continuing with Kim' story,
who is the adult Kim that
you see cooking here,
I'd like to offer some notes
on the Pacific Solution
and its devastating impacts on
refugees and asylum seekers.
Established in 2001 and
promulgated by the red government.
The Pacific Solution was
designed to refuse refugees
on the grounds that Australia needed
to defend its borders against boat people
who were unlawfully entering the country,
arriving on its shores.
And part of the solution
was the rezoning of Christmas island.
Which would no longer
receive asylum seekers
and refugees.
Instead, the Australian government
set up offshore reception
centers in Papua New Guinea
and Nora to outsource the
work of processing refugees.
In 2013 under Rudd's direction
in his second term as prime minister,
a revised version of the
Pacific Solution was rolled out.
In which this newest iteration
of this law formally enacts
the physical detention
of refugees and the
reshuffling of their borders,
of their bodies to any
other place, but Australia.
And of course the precursor
to these solutions
was the problem that Indo-Chinese refugees
as both people had posed when
they first came to Australia
in the 1970s up to the 1980s.
At the time much of
Australian conservative
political discourse
positioned the end of Chinese
as imposters and not bonafide refugees.
Understood as having
left Vietnam by choice
and out of economic need.
So with these overlapping
historical contexts
that begin the film,
Do's work insists on restoring
the narratives of Vietnamese boat people
in speaking to the
Vietnamese-Australian refugee community
and other refugee irregular
maritime migrants,
as they're called in Australian media,
who have been refused
recently by the government.
And these connective
tissues between boat people
and recent refugees book in the film.
And it begins with Australia's
xenophobic political
discourse and ends on a commemoration
of Vietnamese boat people.
The closing intertitles reveal that,
"around 600,000 of an estimated
1.5 million Vietnamese
who fled their country by boat
between 1975 and 1996 perished at sea."
So with this next clip,
I wanted to show how he,
Khoa Do actually visualizes
this boat passage within
a garment factory space.
And it's what once very beautiful
and poignant and other times,
very derealized formally,
because one has to fill in the spaces
of the space of the boat.
And so here's a quick
clip to exemplify that.
- (speaking in foreign language)
(thunder rumbling)
- I'm gonna get some more food.
- Food.
- How long you been out here for?
- Three weeks.
- So I'll stop there, but
you can see the steeples of,
you know, the red cones
of thread in the back.
You see this kind of rusted
manufacturing equipment
that offer viewers an
imaginative invitation
to see that this is the pull of the boat.
And so in so doing, it forces the viewer
to imagine the imaginable, unimaginable
with sounds and images of water
as pneumonic devices that allow the viewer
to be wrapped up in, or I'm sorry,
wrapped up in the emotional
tides of the film.
So as it plays out,
as you see the main protagonists here
are the two sisters
and the one of the sisters do not survive.
So my dual focus in terms of looking
at La Pierre de l'Attente and Mother Fish,
is to look at both the
setting and the sound.
Both the familiarity of these
stories in their formalism
as a way to alienate in (indistinct) way,
the viewer from the surroundings.
They are, all of these elements
are part of the criticality
that I believe Tran Anh
Hung and Khoa Do wields,
wield in producing refugee centered films
that in turn speak to and about refugees.
Which I think leads us
to the other two films
that I'd like to speak about
within the first two set of films,
we are very much in a private space
and I think Forgetting Vietnam and Nuoc
are also two films that talk about water
and sea, in ways that
more obviously to me,
or more apparently to me
through what I call is a
trans-Vietnamese feminist lens.
So I want to talk about
in the next portion,
in this presentation about
the caring for the living
and for the dead.
And it's a trip that I find
as a critical refugee scholar,
very compelling in reading
the cultural productions
of the Vietnamese diaspora.
Refugee memory and critical inquiry
are what I see as being centralized
in these two films in such ways
that these experimental works
by women and queer filmmakers,
expound on water, silence, and intimacy,
but also the open, breaks
open the possibility
of critiquing the state and allowing
for a queer sociality within these spaces.
So, as I argue for both of the films,
water is especially
incubative and maternal,
the source of life giving properties,
as well as the holder of secrets
against the Vietnamese state.
And I'll be talking about,
Forgetting Vietnam first,
it's dedicated to the memories of those
who survived the war.
And the film forges then
a critique of the state,
and is really lined with
memories of the hereness
of the country, which is
captured on digital video,
but also the absent bodies of those
who did not survive the boat passage.
Whose bodies are not actually
represented on screen either.
And my argument is that
you hear these stories
and you see the images
and you hear the lapping
of the waves and the, again,
those devices are pneumonic devices
for us to remember and
reimagine those dead bodies.
So Forgetting Vietnam, archives personal
and collective memory
by way of a travel log.
Touring Vietnam in this
way is important for me
in just seeing how a diasporic identity
through Trinh T. Minh-ha's
perspective is a sieve
through which the works
affects are filtered.
And it's marked by the state,
this diasporic perspective
is marked by the state as an outsider,
a former trader to the nation.
But with this kind of subjectivity,
this Vietnamese diasporic
subject is allowed,
I think a way in to critique the state.
Forgetting Vietnam is critical
of the state's ongoing
operations to forget and
erase the histories of those
who have survived the war,
doing so by representing war again
as the keeper of secrets and knowledge.
And in this short clip,
we have a Vietnamese bus driver
talking about these secrets.
And one of the things
that Trinh T. Minh-ha does
throughout the film actually is to conjoin
the idea that Nuoc and Dat, or Dat Nuoc
are conjoined together in Vietnamese
and Vietnamese diasporic memories.
And so while we're, he's
talking the bus driver,
we see expanses and expanses of land,
most notably of rice fields.
Later on the film has a lot of shots
of moving waters as well.
But in this clip, we hear
then the ways in which the,
the people, working
class people of Vietnam
are often very critical of the state.
- [Male Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Female Voiceover]
(speaking in foreign language)
[Male Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
(man laughing)
(cock crowing)
So Forgetting Vietnam addresses
how both land and water
as that Dat Nuoc
constitute the country's
complex memory scape,
signaled by these images
of land and water,
the film most insistingly cites the sea as
(speaks in Vietnamese).
As more amniotic than traumatic.
In Trinh's Forgetting Vietnam
makes a case then for the ways that water
stores knowledge and
retains memories of those
that had been disappeared by their state.
A notion reinforced by the fact that Nuoc,
as the film notes early on
means both water and country
and invokes the origin story of
(speaks in foreign language).
Whereby the separation of the people
has been born out of loss and love.
Forgetting rehearses the
country's original trauma
of separation to reflect
then upon the divisions
that have also striated
Vietnam's past and present,
the painful divisions that
have marked north and south,
as well as the divisions between
Vietnam and the diaspora.
I'm gonna move on to
Quyen Nguyen-Le's Nuoc
because if Trinh T. Minh-ha
filmed dwells on Dat Nuoc
to speak of Vietnam and
warn against its forgetting
of refugee lives.
Le's 6-minute short Nuoc concretizes
the imagery of Vietnamese land,
specifically its production
of rice and water
through the evocations
of food and food making.
So that what runs through
the film are acts of making
and eating food specifically chao
or rice porridge, which is constituted
by both rice and water.
In fact, liquids run as a current
from beginning to end were first situated
in a photography dark room where chemicals
and water are used to
create memory and culture.
Most specifically of photographs of family
and of the war.
And the associations between
the gender queer subject
that is at the heart of the film
and the mother become more
clarified as the film continues.
And what we have on
this image that you see
is that Qhua the mother
and Rosie eat chao.
The scenes are composed
of a concise study,
they compose a concise study in the ways
that the two subjects are often nourished,
not only through daily food,
but also through the vital
stories they tell one another.
The emphasis on these
unspectacular refugee acts,
as they're recreated in
refugee cultural productions is
critical as Espiritu and I have argued.
The every day and the intimacies
between diasporic subjects
are the foundations
for what we argue are feminist alliances
and refugee knowledges.
A feminist refugee epistemology appears
in the everyday objects
within a context of
silence and quiet tune.
And allows us to see the feminist
and queer visual practices
by which refugee artists
reclaim the private space as
a gendered and queered space,
expressive of loss and grief,
but also of creative improvised
and experimental refugee making practices.
So here, as you'll see in the clip,
there is a primal
relationship between mother
and gender queer subject that constitutes
the film's main affective artery.
Just to give you some context,
what you see is Rosy here
in performing a kind of
gestational labor, pulling
out a bloody umbilical cord.
And then there's a very
quick juxtaposition
to another scene of Rosie being pulled out
of a boat by her mother, by their mother.
(upbeat music)
(suspenseful music)
(birds chirping)
(rain tapping)
- (speaking in foreign language)
- I think she'd like that too.
(gentle music)
- So as earlier,
you saw a painful scene
of gestation and labor
whereby Rosie tries to get the cord out,
but with the same kind of
pulling gesture in the next shot,
we see the mother pulling
Rosie out of water
onto a boat in effect saving their life
and steering them towards safety.
So water here is a life-giving power
that's vested in the maternal figure.
And it illuminates on the
grief that is inherited
between the generations,
between those subjects
who have survived the war,
as seen in the figure of Qhua the mother,
and those who have survived its aftermath
those who are like Rosie as
a second generation subject.
In the metaphorical and
affective registers of the film
fluidity between these temporalities,
spatial geographies, genders
as well as generations
is symbolized by water.
Water is this liquid
encasement that fuses together
mother with motherland, life
with a queer feminist lineage
and that which binds the diasporic subject
to the motherland or Nuoc.
So that it's appropriate
that in the concluding scene
of the film, it features rain
as the iterative act of cleansing
and renewal and it demonstrates
how the two protagonists come
together surrounded by water.
Their mundane act of eating, sharing food,
and silence becomes an
opening between them,
a revolutionary act of making space
for queerness within the home.
As seen in the last line of dialogue,
the mother invites Rosie's
friend to eat in their home
to eat chao.
In Nuoc, the complicated labors
that the diasporic subject
has to navigate is affected by
way of a meaningful dialogue,
a dialectical relationship with
both mother and mother land.
So in conclusion, in the
films that I've analyzed here
from La Pierre de
l'Attente to Mother Fish,
Forgetting Vietnam to Nuoc,
water archives the lives
and memories of the Vietnamese diaspora.
Some of whom work to
illuminate on the refugee hoods
that have lined their family
histories and their memories.
And in closing,
I end here on a shot
from Trinh T. Minh-ha's
Forgetting Vietnam and I contend here
and elsewhere for the
critical modes of diasporic
and refugee ways of knowing
that occur in silence,
speech, in images of art and film
in terms of water and ocean.
And I conjoin the study of
diasporic refugee cinema
with a focus on water,
to gesture towards country, sustenance
and the maternal at once.
And I conjoin the study of cinema
with critical refugee studies,
as well as trans-Vietnamese feminism.
In conclusion,
I'd like to emphasize that
the waters of the ocean
as framed in these four films,
as heard in these four films,
in its beauty and volatility
has contained the bodies of refugees,
but also holds in its expansive folds,
the possibility of knowledge.
And such epistemologies
continue to inspire refugee art
and diasporic art media and criticism.
And it behooves us to look and listen in.
Thank you.
- Thank you Lan, so much
for this wonderful talk.
So we will now open the,
open it up to Q&A.
Let me see, I'm gonna
stop the screen share.
- Yeah.
- Or maybe you can do it on your side?
So we can see everybody.
- Okay, nice.
- I'm going to say in
advance that my computer
just crashed a moment at the
very beginning of the talk.
So if I disappear, keep talking
and I'll try to get back on.
- Okay.
- But so basically anyone
who has a question,
you can use the hand raise function
and I'll call on you and create a queue.
And then we'll proceed from there.
Quan, you have a question, go ahead.
- Thanks so much Lan for
this very generative talk.
I was really struck by your praising
of how refugee memories, you
know, emerge and facilitate
and are on display in
unspectacular places.
And I think of, you know,
there's also in the context of water
in the Vietnamese context,
water can also be very spectacular, right?
So I'm thinking about flood.
I'm thinking about the
salinization of fresh water
and those are also sites of
refugee producing dynamics.
So I was just wondering if you could
maybe speak a little bit
more on sort of this,
you know, water as a
trope, water as a metaphor,
but also the differentiation
between different
kinds of water, if that
resonate in your work.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you Quan.
So in my writing, I've talked
about water in its more,
I guess, generative and productive modes
as a space of loss.
But from that loss, the
generation of memories
and stories and knowledges.
In other ways, water can be
and I wanted to pull out that
tension a little bit more,
water can be very threatening,
water especially in Vietnamese
horror films, (chuckles)
which I claim to have
knowledge on actually,
because I've taught Asian horror
films and write about them.
Water is a dangerous element,
to be submerged in water
and to die in the water
is to be away from one's home,
ancestral home and to be bloated.
And so that is something to be feared
and it's a horrifying aspect
of some of the horror films
that I've looked at.
And in so, in terms of flooding,
which is a very important,
critical fact of Vietnamese life,
I would love to think about
its productive properties
and the ways in which it
actually brings people together.
And I don't know if this
is going in the direction
that you wanted me to
take you to, (chuckles)
but there is a comedy or
a movie called Booyah.
And I recently seen it,
unfortunately (chuckles)
because I have a tendency
to watch bad Vietnamese films.
But so in the setting of that film,
the family comes together
because then they're in an alley
and the film has scenes of flooding
within this family community space.
And it's that water that
brings them together.
And as the film continues,
it's what brings them together,
bonds them together as a unit.
But also as the story goes,
also the family unit is broken
apart by these lingering
resentments and family bonds.
So I think that there
are ways we could argue
for how water can be very multivalent
in lived experiences in Vietnam,
Vietnamese lived experiences.
But then also how allegorically in film,
and for me aesthetically,
how water acts as an agent
in many ways to conjure,
to act as a mnemonic device
to remember and to grieve.
Thank you, Quen.
- I'm gonna jump in on that
because I was thinking
during the whole presentation
about (indistinct)
because that film,
I think actually gives you
a really great opportunity
to speak about that
double meaning of flood
as both like disaster and regeneration,
'cause the whole setting of that film
is about the way in which the floods come,
but they also create the
opportunity for, you know,
regeneration of life and
all those kinds of things,
but it creates this kind of
traumatic setting as well, right?
And I think the history
of the Mekong Delta
in many ways kind of actually
stereotypically sometimes
even Northern Vietnamese
when they will talk
about the Mekong Delta
as this kind of place
of immense fertility, you know,
it's a huge stereotype,
but it's persistent, right?
They used to say like,
you can go to the Mekong Delta
and just stick your hand in the
water and you'll get a fish.
And that's why Southern
Vietnamese people are, you know,
have an easier life
than Northern Vietnamese
people or something.
But at the same time,
there's also this deep history of flooding
also the future-
- [Male Voiceover] Thank
you for calling (indistinct)
- Is under threat.
- Right.
- [Erik] So that, I just thought that'd
be a really interesting angle to look at
and also his follow-up film Nuoc,
but I forget the year
that's 2030 or something.
- 2030. Mmh-hmm.
- Yeah, so Nuoc 2030 also has this kind of
double edge to it.
But my question for you is
about the temporality of this,
this phrase you used when you
were talking about the sea
as becoming amniotic,
as opposed to traumatic.
And I say temporality
'cause I'm wondering,
does it make sense to say
there's a historical shift
in the symbolic meaning of the sea?
Like for example, because you
know, immediately after 75,
the sea can have a kind
of traumatic symbolism,
but then perhaps historically over time,
the meaning of the sea
becomes recuperated in some kind of way.
And or is it just sort
of a flexible symbol
that can change in the
hands of a different artist
or something like that.
- Right. I think.
And so I'm gonna agree
with your last final,
your second point about it's
fluidity and it's flexibility
to hold different kinds of
allegorical and critical import.
And I'm not arguing that then water
is a temporal or a historic,
but I am looking very specifically
about how Vietnamese diaspora
and refugees are using
this element of water
to draw on it's historical
and cultural significance
in Vietnamese culture and in
Vietnamese lived experiences,
but also to focus on the,
how the diaspora understands,
I think through water,
what home and home land mean.
So once it's flexible, on the other hand,
how I'm understanding water
for the Vietnamese diaspora
filmmakers that I look at,
they're very specific to how water seems
to contain secrets and knowledge as well
as the actual dead bodies of refugees.
And I'm happy to see that
(indistinct) is here,
I don't wanna call her out,
but her brother did both films.
And so happy to see
you. It's been so long.
And I do talk about Nuoc 2030.
I think it's a beautiful film.
And speaking of temporality then,
the fact that it's so centrally
placed in a scientific,
or sci-fi imaginary of
(speaking in foreign language)
being submerged by the sea.
I think there is so much
to talk about in that act,
in that actuality of being flooded,
the actuality of environmental harm
and the perhaps, you know,
the generative notion of
water as a way to understand
a kind of futurity that
hasn't really been,
I think dealt with in some
of the Vietnamese films
that I've seen.
So it is definitely
important to talk about
Minh's work in this context as well.
- Thanks, there's another
question from Tien Nguyen.
- Hi professor Lan.
Thank you for your presentations.
My questions for you is
that I see in four clips
that you present in your presentations,
the like of urban scapes.
And as I would wonder if the relationship
between the symbolic water
and the water body has something related
with the more underdeveloped past
of Vietnamese contemporary,
Vietnamese society,
to the diasporic community focus
on how to, portraying
water as something related
with poverty and economics
under development or not,
or if there's any other
interpretations on the water
relating with urban
scapes and urbanizations.
Thank you.
- So you noticed Nien
that there are scenes
of urban spaces in
perhaps a film, like Nuoc,
like Quyen Nguyen-Le's but
there's also where they are
in a suburban home
finally, eating together
and ending on that note of offering chao
to Rosie's friend, queer friend.
And then also in Khoa Do's Mother Fish,
we begin with the older
sister Gim preparing food
within the kitchen.
Is that, are these the spaces
that you're talking about?
- Yes.
Well then I also think
of entertainments has
for what your clip's showing it's that
when she's returning to Vietnam
or when she filmed it in Vietnam,
the waters and the lands,
kinda like having the sense
of like the more rural spaces
rather than the urban spaces
and Tran Anh Hung's films
is basically in a refugee camp.
- Yeah, and a Parisian apartment.
So yeah, there is that duality,
I think of being in both land and water.
I think that's part of the
dialectic that Trinh T. Minh-ha
wants to emphasize into the work.
And I think that the
observation that you make
about these different spaces is key
to my larger argument about
how refugees reimagine
in very particular ways,
how the boat passage has,
how they have experienced the boat passage
through actual lived memories
or through post memories
and how then there's
a continuity from that space.
Like for example, in the refugee camp,
to the Parisian apartment,
there's a continuity between
forms of waiting in that camp
to forms of waiting in
the apartment building.
And in fact, the apartment
building that we see
is actually less dreary,
is much more dreary than the refugee camp.
And so that juxtaposition
of these different spaces,
I think allows us to see the kinds of
psychological states too, of their,
of refugee subjectivities
and their memories,
and how the associations
between the home life
and workspace are really
flooded to use a term
we talked about before,
flooded with memories
of the boat passage, of
refugee life, of refugee death.
So thank you Nien for that observation.
Hi Qui Ha
- Hi Lan.
Thank you so much for your
wonderful presentation
on the topic refugees cinema,
which is just amazing
because in film studies,
it's just a bit more than one,
the first, second, and
third cinema. (chuckles)
And now you talk about the fifth cinema.
I'm so glad to learn more about it
and learn more about, you know,
outside the first and
the second, (chuckles)
which is great to explore
that kind of possibilities
to think of cinema outside
of western oriented
or based theories.
So I really appreciate,
and I'm very, you know,
inspired by your discussion of water
as a troop in diasporic filmmakers films.
And also the ways that is represented
as a archive of refugees memories.
I have a particular question in terms of
not only the representation,
but I'm curious,
like if you, in your work
broader, you know, project,
would you discuss anything
about, for example,
the kind of like, this is
not just the representation,
but the way that cinema is worse actually
brought to from the country
to outside of the country.
Because like recently,
I think two years ago,
I read a case study,
I don't remember what is the film title,
but it is about a film
that was lost on the ways
a film maker brought it with him,
but then it's lost somewhere
and then somebody took it
and then later into Hong Kong.
And then it's returned
to him in Australia.
So I think that kind of,
consider theme as an
object, which traveled,
you know, on water as a, you know,
this is more in the physical terms
rather than a representational terms.
I mean, like that part
it's wonderful already,
so I'm wondering if you, you
know, consider in that sense.
And also the second
question I'm curious is,
you discussed the representation
in diasporic films,
and I'm wondering if you discuss
it within the connections
to the Vietnamese film
tradition or only focus
on that part, like
Jeffrey's cinema and yeah,
that is the questions that I have.
Thank you.
- I really like the first question.
I like the second too,
but the first question about
the materiality of films
and how they too have traveled on sea,
at sea and through waterways.
I think that's something
that I want to look about,
look into a lot more closely
because some of the films that were made
in pre '75 Saigon for example,
did have to make it outside
of the country in '75.
And I can think of a couple of examples,
for example, with Qiu Jin's work,
who left Vietnam in '75
and who had to transport
some of her beloved films with her.
I don't think she went by sea,
but it was a mode of
travel in which she felt
like these were material
and cultural artifacts
that needed to be saved.
Another mode of travel through airplanes
that Vietnamese films
have traveled through
is when the Library of Congress,
oh, I'm sorry.
When the American government
in withdrawing from Vietnam
also took a lot of films,
especially done by the US government
and brought them to the
Library of Congress.
And that's where a lot of
these films are archived.
And then finally, in the
more contemporary version
of traveling films, we now
have a very vibrant passageway
between Vietnam and the diaspora
in terms of films, whereby Vietnamese,
the Vietnam Film Festival
in Orange County,
often invites directors
and films from Vietnam
to screen their works.
And we have then another passage
of Vietnamese American directors,
for example, from California,
who go to Saigon
specifically to make films.
So in this context,
films and filmmakers are
constantly circulating.
And so that's an interesting geography
that I'm, that I've
looked into in my work.
So, and it relates to the
second question we have,
because this is where
my method of analysis
trans-Vietnamese feminism
tries to put into place.
And that is if I'm looking at something
in terms of the Vietnamese diaspora,
I'd like to see how too
Vietnamese filmmakers
have looked at or represented water.
So as you know, there is
along the same river of
the famous, you know,
film of two lovers who are
separated at the 17th parallel
between north and south,
they are surrounded by water.
And I talk about how
that kind of passageway
between north and south peasants,
because they're also fishers
are treated differently
in a communist film like that.
And so, and water has more
of a kind of pragmatic way of travel.
We see a lot of traveling on the women
on the perfume river, for
example, by (indistinct).
And she uses it as also a way to
it's a space for her sex work on the boat.
And so finally in another
film called (indistinct).
The woman who's just been
raped, played by (indistinct)
goes to the ocean, and she's
about to commit suicide.
And then she turns around because
she hears her baby crying.
And it's at this point
of this very poignant,
pivotal moment where she
realizes that she will mother
the country and mother, and
continue to mother her child.
At that moment,
we get a juxtaposition of the ocean
plus her breast and she
is breastfeeding the baby.
So there are different ways
in which Vietnamese directors
have understood water and ocean.
And it's in my writing that
I try to tease out those
important differences
and attachments to water.
- Thanks Qin Ha.
- It's wonderful. Thank you so much.
I look for what you're reading
your writings on this topic very much.
- Thanks.
- We're basically at the
end of our time here,
usually what I do is I
stop the recording now,
and then we keep it open for a few minutes
for informal chitchat.
So let's all,
join me in a round of applause
and then I'll stop the recording.
(people clapping)
- (chuckles) Thank you.